what is lighting and why do we light
lighting yeah it's funny when i started
lighting
uh in grad school
it was purely motivated
by exposure i was shooting on film i
started shooting on reversal
16 which is you know difficult
to light and does not have much latitude
and if you screw up
it's gone and so i was lighting
purely to have exposure
so if you looked at some of the films
that student films that i had lit
there was nothing attractive about them
but they were exposed
but now you know i suppose it goes back
to like your question about a great shot
or something
it's it's intention it's always
intention
so it's trying to enhance
whatever mood you're looking for is
be that something is you know beautiful
or scary or and you know there is
also um i don't know where this
where or when this started but when i'm
on set
very often there will be and i don't
know what it is and this is tricky
uh is i'll be looking at an image
on monitor and we'll be lighting it
and it won't feel like anything that's
what i'll say i'll be like this isn't
something like this isn't i don't what
does it need and sometimes i don't know
and so i'll go back to okay when i when
i'm
feeling lost like a shot isn't working
i'll go back to
what is the scene where is this
character right now
and okay if this is the emotion
what does that mean to me in terms of
lighting and then you know i interpret
it however i
interpret or i talk to my gaffer or
director or key grip
and and i'll kind of talk it out and
feel it out and
sometimes it takes some experimenting
but there is this thing it's not the
best way to work but it's
how i've worked for years now where
we'll start futzing if i'm if i'm
feeling like this
shot isn't doing what i want it to do
the light isn't doing what i want it to
do
like well what if we turn that off and
and we'll well what if
okay maybe take away the diffusion there
and then something will happen
and i'm like oh this is something like i
don't like now it feels like something
it like has
personality to it and it's such a it's
really difficult to explain
because the truth is i often don't know
why i i can't you know i do all my prep
work so i try to
um marinate in in the show's intention
it shows mood a show's atmosphere
but then you know when you're shooting
shot after shot and you're on
the 1000th shot of a
show that you're shooting and you're
trying to find something and it's not
there
i really and part of it feels like a
little bit of magic i don't know what
that
is but the light i'm ver i'm always
very conscious of light and sometimes it
just doesn't feel
right and i don't even know what that
means like what is right what if there's
no such thing as right or wrong
but something in me
is not responding to what we're doing
and and
very often it's uh it's because of the
light
and so it's it's not much of a specific
answer
but that is
something and the leader is the
intention the intention of a scene the
intention of like just
just trying to think of where your
characters are
and sometimes a light can be too
dominant or
sometimes it's not enough or sometimes
it's drawing the eye to the wrong place
because it can you know just like a door
frame and
a shaft of light like these are all ways
to direct
the eye and so i think for light it's
it's just another tool another way to
direct the eye
and direct intention or mood i guess
so a bit of a babbling answer but it's
kind of how i feel about it sometimes it
just is this mishmash of
concepts that you're trying to hone in
and then
something clicks you're like yeah that's
what it is
it's weird and referring back to pen 15
your hulu project the two two uh one and
two
um you said with that one it was not to
make scenes pretty
right so with the lighting again you
were not using any kind of fillers or
yeah it was so yeah
how would we approach so you know i mean
so the show's naturalistic
uh in general and so
i mean some of the basics are if we're
in a bedroom
the light is going to if it's bedroom
daytime
and that's a big part of it i work with
the script supervisor very closely for a
number of reasons but one of them is i
like to track
time of day it doesn't mean i'm going to
always stick to it
but you know i always am checking with
her i'm like okay
so this scene is this like you know two
o'clock and she's like actually no it's
like five o'clock
and so some i'm like oh okay so then
we'll we'll lower the sun that's coming
in a window so it'll
and we let how it might actually be
lead the scene that that'll at least be
if you think of it as like a hunk of
clay that you're shaping
you just getting the hunk is like where
to even start
and that's often what it is it's like
okay it's 5 p.m
we're about to go to dinner with these
kids so it should not so it should be a
little darker let's start
and so part of it is smoothing out
transitions because you know the next
scene
is just night and so it's like okay well
you don't want to jump from
noon to night unless you want to jump
from noon to night
and so you let the the way it would
actually be you let that be the leader
so a lower sun coming in the side and
then you decide
with with everybody you know the art
crew and the directors like okay these
blinds
open closed it's going to change the
look in the room
and you can intention should always be
the leader but sometimes
you're just you're like okay i don't
this is too bright
okay well then maybe we throw a tree
branch in front of it try and break it
up we
diffusion or maybe it's a cloudy day you
want it to feel like a cloudy day or
feel like a sunny day
and these are all decisions i mean it's
it that's really what a lot of it is
it's just a ton of small decisions
that hopefully are being led by
a concept and then eventually you find
yourself
in a place that feels right and i think
that helps i think
when you lead with intention and you
know
what the character's state of mind is at
a particular time
it really helps because you can make
tons of decisions are the lights on in
the room are they off
is the overhead on there's the lamp on
are the blinds open are the blinds
closed is it cloudy is it sunny is it
rainy is
is the sun over here because you decide
you know was or should we put the sun
there
it you can get overwhelmed by options
but if you have places to start if you
know the story if you know the
characters that at least
gives you can at least point your ship
in a direction and i think
that for me at least uh is huge that's
everything otherwise i'd go insane
because you can light any scene a
million different ways
there were a lot of scenes where the the
two protagonists were in front of their
lockers
and sort of like the horrific halls
of the junior high and and sort of the
the the baroness and ugliness of of you
know you're on display for everyone
yeah yeah no and that's and we debated
uh especially in season one when we were
shooting locker
scenes by the locker in the ugly hallway
you're like well
you know the light people tend to look
better
if the light is coming from the
non-camera side
just in terms of if you're just you know
no intention or anything
it's just nice if it's coming from the
opposite side people
it'll be flatter if it's coming from the
camera
and so we'd start to lean into that but
then we're like well
but they're in the school hallway where
they feel exposed and they
feel like uncomfortable so maybe that's
actually good
is that you do it what might be the
wrong way you know
and and and you're juggling those
decisions
and sometimes your intention is one
thing and then you look at it and you're
like well it just doesn't work
and then you try it another way and for
whatever reason it works and you respond
to it
uh but i think that's also part of it is
being in being in tune with everything
and seeing what you respond to because
it's just so
arbitrary in a way the way that i'm
going to respond to something doesn't
mean everyone will
but you hope that if if your intentions
are dialed in
and that's what's leading your decisions
that's kind of the sum
of all of those parts leads to it
feeling the way you want it to feel
i guess